今日はこちら cd カフェです今日は言葉の勉強についてまた話しします
まあ日本で一番よく勉強されている言語はもちろん英語ですけども
一つのアドバイス
あの英語の勉強ま他の言葉でも同じですけれどもすべてのドルーテスト
クイズ
え
練習提出その他やらないでください
逆に立たないですつまらないです
意味がないです
なぜかというとですね言葉の勉強というのはその頭脳がねぇ
脳がだんだん
ダウンドン慣れてくるわけですよそれには2つの要素が必要です1つは繰り返し
1つは新しい新しいなよ興味のあるないよ面白いものそれが必要なんですよ
聞くよしかしその分布の説明はねぇ
大体においては我々は分からない動い今度にその英語の場合ちょっとれよう
みんな3へ出しますけれども
そしてそのその分布の説明よりも
もっと
その時間のムダ遣いというのはすべての練習
すべてのクイズぶるーるー
あの残念ながらですね言葉の勉強英語の勉強の本にはねでビール
たくさんありまースクイーズあそれは一切やらないでください
繰り返しじゃないですよディルやればもう一度
っていうのはね何が必要かというとあのまず
たくさん面白いその内容を聞いたり読んだりすることですけれどもその部分に関しては
ねぇ
ちょちょっとした説明そしてたくさんの0
それを見ればある程度
あの役に立ちます簡単な説明
沢山の0名付けて言うとその説明わからないで美々卯5分も同じですよ
ジェリーを見てあーくそのパターンがねそのうち普通に読んだり聞いたりする時にです
ねそのパターンがあの現れてくるけれども集中的に
か
このパターンはこうですよと
そのたくさんの例を出して猫の説明に対してこれが例ですよとそれであのたります
何もそれじゃあ今度練習しましょうその
ナンですからねマーレー4 a
あの見せしますこの方はねぇ
非常に有名な方なんですよ
まあ日本では多分間によってそんな有名じゃないけれども
来食ブルーと
街にですねたくさんの票が英語を勉強するために来るんですよ
そしてこちらの本屋さんいきますとそしてまあインターネットです
youtube の対しられたらこの方がですね非常に有名
ですよベリー4レーザー
でこの本も有名ですねそしてあの
どこでもいっしょ開いてみればですね
者の説明4ディグリーズソープ d
プレゼンタイムね下丁
anger スピーカー srt me be this bed フィリーズの
パース besame
voodoo バーバーこういうような細かい説明はですねー
たくさん聞いたり読んだりいろんな面白い内容を通じてん
その脳がそれにだんだん慣れてくるとですねおのづからわかってくるんですよ
分かってくるっていうよりも小野ぞから正しく理解できるようになる
正しく使えるようになるしかしそれには
たくさーんたくさんキー
voodoo スト
ポレの説明に台北 sr プリプ sanus abc バーブ axe to see
x アイズナー axes 店 xi 頭がぁ船中ソイと
すべて役に立たないです1歳
こういう本はプーフ
してればいいですよそして普通の言葉の勉強の本にでもですね
あの内容っていうか聞ける読める
場合によってはもう広い内容というのは少ないですよ20%
8割が即雑な説明
もともと言葉というのは複雑ですよこういうこともあるばしかし場合によっては老害的
にこういうこともあるだろうと
それをいくらに説明書と思えばなかなか
わけがわからないんですよそれよりも自然的にそれに慣れてくるとまぁ最初は60
アーセン70%80%んあの徐々に徐々にもっと正確にそれをあのその正しく理解
できるようになりますよ
正しく使えるようになりますで場合によってじゃあ確認のためにその文法について
ちょっと調べたいときにそれじゃ
館
店説明簡単な説明沢山の0
簡単な説明沢山の0練習クイズルール
テスト一切なし役に立たない
つまらないそして必ずそのテストをやるときに
さん
者の何ですか誤解が出るんですよミスが出るんですよ
失敗がでるじゃあ党に対して8しか湧かなかったとか6とかそれが勉強する人が
フラストレーション感じます
しかし
聞いたもの聞いた内容それが100%無わからなくてもいいから
だから理解に対するうテストも一切ダメ私は聞いた内容
半分しかわからなかった構いませんその半分は良かったあとの半分まぁちょっとこう
あいまいでよ
わからないけれども構わないですこれが少し時間経つと続けて読めば続けた
続けば続けて聞けばだんだんとそのはっきりしたその
分かるような部分が5割から6割から7割
そして運持ちのかな内容によって違います
よなあれ非常にあの
え
しかししたし親しいねないようであればその理解の割合がもっと高い
全然あの関係のない内容であれば理解できるものは
元少ないけれども続ければ続ければだんだんと
名がグルになってくるんだから
aj 5にん
突発するためにたくさん読んでたくさん聞いて
テストでいる一切やらないでそして場合によっては文法の説明見て簡単な身近な
3時から説明沢山の0それでもまぁ一度読んだり聞いたり頭って話する話するそれでは
まあ今日の
メインのポイントでしたじゃどこパターン
頑張ってください